edgert the opening plenary this week you
had a call to action to the industry
tell us about some of the main elements
of that yeah the call to action that we
have called out last year is actually a
five pillar plan and I won't know them
all five because it's really too dull
but in the most important thing is that
they're all five they're interconnected
which in first instance wouldn't
wouldn't look like that so it's like
about customer transparency its
technology neutrality it's creating a
business-friendly environment just to
name three of them but in the end they
are all in Delhi to connect it for me
the most important thing is that it all
starts with like also mentioned in the
opening session is that is all starts
with competition so we believe that
competition is driving the investment in
fiber their own infrastructure and he
also creates innovation and innovation
but by default is also going to create
the growth water for Europe so just to
take a small highlight there's a big
debate going on right now on the digital
divide and mainly the rural areas where
but as a lack of fiber and broadband
penetration we are quite passionate
about it because of the digital divide
we believe that if you build a network
you should build it once and that's
definitely true in the rural areas it
needs to be future-proof and I think one
of the highlights out of my opening
speech it was actually the the point
that the individual ROI of a network
especially in rule sometimes is not
usually to look at the bigger picture of
the social benefit of the network and
especially in these rural areas when
youngsters are moving out and moving
into this into city areas that can be
halted and even bring back to businesses
to these rural areas because of
broadband so that will create economic
growth for the region we enumerate that
region again and that's why we're so
passionate about also the rural
broadband and to really connected also
this is where we believe that the
European funding or the junker plan
investment plan should really focus
themselves on to make sure that the
investments is going to be in the areas
where the social benefits exceeds the
local individual roi but just one small
example of the five pillars because it
incorporates everything that we have 25
that's what I doing but it's a good call
for action and is actually trying to
make sure that everybody not only we as
fabula arm counsel with our members with
the industry members but also the
operators the legislators policymakers
to understand we're all in this together
so it's not a competition between one to
the other competition is needed but in
the end we need to make sure that we
believe and that we need to go for the
only future proof solution which is
fiber and of course it came just before
all the latest figures were names which
show some very encouraging growth right
of Algeria yeah definitely so I'm quite
enthusiastic about the numbers that were
presented we all should be aware that
Europe is not one country it's 28
countries will even look at the 39th
other countries right now we have three
new entrants be Quebec economies I'm
quite proud to announce that the the
last year the country of last year's
conference Warsaw was XD Poland was
coming in and Croatia and and finally
also Germany made the one percent
threshold so no that's a positive person
so I've always look at the positive side
but it's only 1% so there's still a lot
to do especially the biggest big
economies but in general I think when
you look at the list now the list is now
29 countries that are meeting the one
percent threshold so it's quite a long
list already but I think the the good
thing when you really look at the total
scale is that the that the general trend
is just growing so it's year-on-year
growth is mainly in homes past but also
in subscription is really picking up and
we have a couple of countries where
they're actually the take-up is above
fifty percent sixty-five percent and
even more of that and that's really
encouraging so people want fiber when
they get access to fiber they even take
a subscription but again you know it's
not one country so one area is little
bit more growing the other one is
plateauing because they already reached
on the percent like lithuania in these
areas they already have full fiber
access so and Western European countries
are a little bit in a different dynamic
but also there you see Spain and France
really picking up so no quite
enthusiastic about the dynamics that we
present
yesterday when the growth the vibrancy
seems reflected here at the conference
where there's been an enormous
attendance and in fact we even had the
Prime Minister come to the opening day
yes absolutely so so the flexing it was
actually seen also in the numbers we we
measured obviously the attendance that
are coming here and we have twenty
percent more attendance than last year
even more than a year before in
Stockholm so the gross is coming back
and to me you know it's it's obviously
it's the world's largest
fibre-to-the-home conference and people
tend to come here from globally from the
whole world but i think you know it's
good good conference but in the end it
also helps that the vibrance is coming
into the industry so you can really
reflect that back into the attendance
but it's good to see all these people
walking around and enjoying themselves
do networking talking about this bright
food should that we're talking about and
that we're trying to create so you know
really really pleased about that
absolutely well thank you very much for
talking to us